[Musique]
c'est selon son constructeur monsieur
charles amat d'ozillac en charente
maritime la première bicyclette à six
places circulant enfants cinq places
pour les pédaleurs et une pour un
passager
c'est un jeune qui fait 5 10 de l'ong
120 kg de poires environ et qui peut
dans l'avenir avoir deux places
supplémentaires un tandem dans ce vide
chose qui n'existe pas à l'heure
actuelle pour diminuer l'encombrement
est là et augmenter la puissance et la
vitesse plan atteint eu des gens
entraînés peuvent environ sphère du 45
50 régulier avec l'engin aux points 100
%
[Musique]
est ce que c'est un engin manial très
maniable d'ailleurs
vous pourrez le voir sur les
démonstrations la maniabilité
qui peut lui permettre de figurer sur
sur une route même dans les villes en
virage en équerre
quel est son prix de revient
fait par un artisan il faut emprunter
environ dans les 500 mille anciens
francs est ce que votre avis c'est une
solution d'avenir que les embouteillages
à ce moment là depuis le je n'ai pas
pratiquement le terme employé c'est un
peu long mais pour faire des
déplacements en campagne c'est alors
qu'on a c'est très amusant et c'est
spectaculaire est en train non
[Musique]